c'est une inauguration en grande pompe
qui s'est déroulé depuis riyad à
l'occasion du 14 juillet après arab news
pakistan en 2018 terrab news japon en
2019 le pouvoir saoudien a lancé la
troisième édition numérique
international du principal quotidien
panarabe arab news en français
coronavirus ou glisser par
vidéoconférence que la cérémonie de
lancement a eu lieu en présence du
ministre de la formation saoudien par
intérim
majid el khattabi du directeur du groupe
arab news face à la base mais également
de l'ambassadeur de france à ryad
françois gouyette l'ambassadeur de
france s'est félicitée de cette
initiative et a même salué un symbole
d'amitié entre les deux pays
chers amis en ce 14 juillet 2020 jour de
fête nationale en france j'ai le grand
plaisir d'inaugurer l'édition numérique
d'arabes blues en français
je suis donc très heureux de voir la
direction daragnou choisir aujourd'hui
après pakistan et le japon la france et
sa langue pour sa troisième édition à
l'étranger et surtout pour sa première
édition réalisée intégralement dans une
autre langue que l'envié d'édition
française daragnou j'en suis sûr sera un
nouveau pont entre eux nos cultures
respectives
je vois dans cette initiative la
possibilité pour nos deux pays de mieux
se comprendre de mieux s'apprécie à
l'heure où se multiplient dans le monde
les appels au repli sur soi car c'est
bien connu les bons comptes font les
bons amis et avec pas moins de 9,1
milliards d'euros en 2018 et 8,3
milliards en 2019 d'achat d'armes à la
france nul doute que riyad figure parmi
nos amis les plus chers
soucieuse de redorer sa réputation à
l'international après l affaire
khashoggi l'arabie saoudite par
l'ouverture d'aram nous en français
entend être la vitrine du pouvoir à ryad
incarnée par le prince héritier mohammed
bin salman 10 mb/s
souvenez vous en octobre 2018 ce
journaliste saoudien devenu critique
après avoir été proche du pouvoir avait
été tuée et découpée en morceaux par des
agents saoudiens dans l'enceinte du
consulat du royaume wahhabite à istanbul
un crime horrible qui a remis au centre
du débat la libye
tu es d'expression et la liberté de la
presse dans le royaume saoudien
à l'époque le prince héritier mohammed
ben salmane avait démenti toute
implication dans ce meurtre sans pour
autant nier une certaine responsabilité
de la couronne j'assume toute la
responsabilité du crime en tant que
dirigeant saoudien en particulier parce
que le meurtre a été commis par des
individus travaillant pour le
gouvernement saoudien nouveaux médias
étrangers dans le paysage des médias
francophones arab news en français ce
sont pas moins de 40 employés
journalistes éditeurs ou encore
traducteur sous les ordres de randa
takieddine journaliste libanaise et
spécialiste de la diplomatie française
et diplomatie internationale
le média compte ainsi diffusé auprès des
francophones du monde entier en
s'appuyant notamment sur un réseau de
correspondants au maghreb en belgique ou
encore au canada un canal d'information
étrangers financée par des capitaux
étrangers qui diffuse en langue
française cela nous rappelle un autre
média qui a ouvert son antenne dans
l'hexagone y ait un peu moins de trois
ans mais qui n'a pas suscité le même
engouement auprès des pouvoirs français
l'avenir dira si les hautes sphères de
l'hexagone réserveront le même accueil
que celui dont rt france a bénéficié
vu l'enthousiasmé initial de la
diplomatie française on peut déjà avoir
quelques doutes